aide directe de 4000 personnes
ça fait plaisir donc le match qui va
commencer à 22h20 c'était vraiment
sympathique
moi je me suis je me suis fait plaisir
je me suis fait très plaisir elle me
suis fait très plaisir en 800 je suis
content bon je me vois je suis content
là bas je suis je suis bien je suis je
suis serein je suis heureux je suis
heures
à me retirer
être 1004 1200 r ouais alors attendant
je vais encore faire quelques petits
trucs quelques petits réglages et on va
être bon du coup si vous voyez favori
pour ce match moi je pense ça redonne va
l'emporter
après on va
1 on va voir
va se passer mais moi je vois bien sâr
dossche l'emporter quand même
personnellement carreaux qui cote juste
avant m et coacher juste avant ce n'est
pas forcément une bonne chose
watching une excuse ça fait partie je
suis évidemment pour ça redonne
exception le coaching au coaching juste
avant généralement c'est pas une bonne
chose je vais jeter un oeil mais c'est
pas le genre de coaching qu'on veut
avoir caicos
g
attendez
m
voilà
le coaching je vais le prévenir veut
jouer
désespéré de
à meylan 2
pas se rappeler juste avant le match le
coach
on n'y va pas se rappeler london il va
pas se rappeler mais à la grotte c'est
trop dangereux
ça va ça va
pas de souci
j'ai écrit
non non il a coaché
granby
peur ça valait le london savaria pas de
problème les gars c'est la grotte qu'il
faut pas jouer surtout pas
surtout pas de globe
t'es sûr
est sûr qu il
gr de préparer à mais c'est
le coaching à ça va commencer way i
coach compte london des comptes
l'automne de tiva rien pipés c'est pas
grave la position elle va être correct
qui comprend rien il va pas se rappeler
il va mélanger il va mélanger à part
sans il ya trop d'enjeux peut pas
vraiment dire qu' énormément d'enjeux
non plus et clôt un toute raison garder
ça reste un tournoi un tournoi amateur
certes sympathique à suivre mais c'est
pas les candidats quoi ouais c'est une
bonne
fait trop déjà il fallait qu'ils fassent
moins d'échecs il en a trop fait là il
va arriver frais il va le défoncer en
vrai en vrai va le défoncer ok bon
petit trépas mai
c'est rien c'est rien le truc contre le
london il va il va se tromper par contre
il est 22 heures 20 pourquoi on est en
retard
c'est fou parce qu'il est encore
coachella ça m'énerve en fait ils ont
fait un coaching juste juste avant le
match
attendez
officiel par contre ce top de la dire de
la merde ajouteront la charité et aucun
enjeu non non il ya la moitié des prix
qui vont aux joueurs vingt mille pour
l'association et 20 minutes pour le
joueur pour le vainqueur
j'ai dit que le coaching dix minutes
avant moi ça va déjà fait perdre des
parties des coachings comme ça en fait
j'ai arrêté les coachings minutes avant
parce que ça peut me faire perdre des
partis par contre le coaching sur la
grotte peut être dangereux c'est ça le
truc
est c'est ça le danger
c'est ça le gros danger
ça le gros
et c'est là grob veut dire qu'il se
prépare sur kst this way mais ça il
connaît en fait ça ça faut juste qu'ils
jouent comme ils comme il le sent
dans l'air
et
vas-y base
mais bon dieu écrit
et vas-y jeune et con tre prépa
contrerait pas dit car ou est contre eux
prépa contre eux prépa d'hikaru ça fait
très mal surtout que là ils allaient
blanc en premier
bon allez les gars il faut qu'ils la
gagnent sarnoff celle là non mais c'est
bon il a vu mon message où il y en a
discuté on vient discuter excuces et en
sueur avec la sicilienne c'était sûr que
ça va le mélange et la prépa d'hikaru
juste avant ça va le mélange est fou
c'est 4 c'est déjà erreur si ça non
pourquoi tu te rappelles pas de 6 des
cinq noms aussi ce dessin et pourquoi
tempo des six
[Musique]
ils sont en avait parlé
bon c'est pas grave mais aussi ce dessin
que c'était déjà mieux pour les noirs
parce qu'en fait je vous pourrez vous
expliquer en fait l'idée du fou c4 s'est
tapé ici donc du coup quand vous faites
4,5 pouces et 4 vous tapez sur fcn en
quelque sorte là le truc c'est que 4 c 5
pouces et quatre en fait si tu fais
aussi ce tu bloques le fou ça j'en ai
parlé en plus cédé 5 au prochain il a
fait des si ceux ci c'est quand même pas
mal mais du coup des saints qui perd un
temps allez fouet cette rock et des cinq
plus tard ça va quand même allez allez
c'est pas mal il peut avoir aussi des
a6b seins qui tombent et oui du coup il
s des quatre champions prend cavaliers
prend et rock ça va ça va il n'y a rien
de grave c'est juste que vous c4 est une
erreur et là ça remet les blancs dans
une position plus normal et a6 et là il
va il va vouloir jouer avec des seins
qui est fou bessette ça va ça va il a
joué très vite il met la pression autant
ça peut être une bonne chose
allez mon sarde il faut la gagner
celle-là il faut aller la chercher
normalement il est favori du match
faites gaffe aux lots ça veut pas dire
grand chose les joueurs sont souvent
saouls classé match quand même content
en deux minutes d'avancé à la pendule
hikaru foule stress ah bah oui oui car
ou qui vas tu vas pépon ce soir le
joueur français à l'ebbe stinco fou
bessette tempo alors l'es5 fou mais ça y
est je pense qu'il va partir il faut
jouer vite il carreaux qui transpire
aille car oui doit être comme ça mais
simcoe qui par icare où il est comme ça
en ce moment mais en plus c'est bien
parce que ces prépas avec les blancs
elles vont arriver dans un deuxième
temps ça lui a mis un coup de pression
juste avant le match à des 5 c'est bien
joué 2 minutes d'avancé à peu va ça peut
avoir son importance à ce niveau parce
qu'avec une minute il va avoir du mal à
gérer en franchement je la sens bien
pour sarde
non
juste avant mauvaise idée à l'essai 30
c'est bien ils arguent du temps le fou
et attaqué un pour le moment c'est
solide les v-noirs qui va jouer foulée
700 prend option leucate jouer b4
peut-être après après faire gaffe sur
flu bessette qui est pas les fous qu'on
réussisse parfois alors ça ça peut être
des variantes à regarder ici je pense
que ça va fondamentalement mais ça peut
être c'est hyper dur à leur niveau à
jouer et je n'aimerais pas que ça rentre
là dedans peut-être un petit roxy quand
même pour les noirs histoire deux cas où
parle avec le mec ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
parlent je pense que tu as l'impression
qu'ils parlent ensemble
par contre si coach en même temps ça
s'appelle apprécié eux qui font les
règlements mais a fait voir pense pas
après ça m'étonnerait qu'ils le coach en
même temps je vais aller sur les sites
la jet non non il
à juste non à risque
à juste un ex qc ca sent pas x cusset il
ya une flaque d'eau souvient il parle
même plus là il met de la musique prend
la flaque d'eau la fac d'eau sous x
cusset il dit plus un mot van damme f3
le truc qui est dangereux c'est que il
joue sur la grande diagonale et un petit
un petit fou bessette ça peut être cool
et dubé 4 après là je pense à alain
kouck homme fou bessette c'est vraiment
le coup qui va jouer faux pas qui laisse
aux cimes cauwet bien joué mais bien
jouer un joueur français qui fait mal
cavaliers 17 cas et c'est ça qui va s'en
prendre aux pions qui a aidé sept cas
ralliée aux 5
c'est bien joué
voilà c'est bien phu bessette
bien la dame est très mal placé en f3
elle est en face du fou dans le viseur
et là on veut cavaliers 17 cavaliers c5
des quatre cavaliers prend 1,4 ça peut
aller très vite un c1 deux coups et on
jette d'ailleurs déjà sur le pion qui
commence à être bien visé est cette dame
bah allez allez pas bien elle n'est pas
bien en f3 dameuse d'ailleurs ça c'est
un bon coup par contre belle réaction de
x cusset qui s'est rendu compte de son
erreur et qu'ils jouent d'ahmed trois
dames eux deux mais bon c'est un temps
de gagner maintenant cavalier c'est
cette cavalcade et cette crise et 5
il ya peut-être
il prend le cadre d'ailleurs auquel j'ai
une pensée parce que maintenant c'est la
dame en premier en protection à wimbée
quatre cavaliers 4 c'est le pion cadeau
à les sardes ouvre les yeux à lester mon
conseil pour ce match open your eyes
allez je vais mettre un petit coup
d'ordi je regarde pas avec leur
différence est parti donc je peux rater
beaucoup de tactique mais wimbée quatre
cavaliers à 4 et qui apprend le 4 c'est
quoi le blem prenant ça gagne un pion
est ce qu'il l'a vu mais oui la vue mais
oui monsieur b quattro x qc w on va
rajouter une lettre à son pseudo et oui
mesdames f3 dame e2c un temps de perdu
et c'est grave
et oui je lui ai dit tu ouvres les yeux
tu gagnes le match tu as juste à ouvrir
les yeux
la note à plus de six minutes allaient
faut continuer à jouer assez vite mais
pas trop non plus pour pas faire de
grosses d'erreurs et cavaliers prend 1,4
faut plutôt prendre du cavalier en
général on préfère mettre les cavaliers
au centre de l'échiquier
les x arrivent plus tard au centre c'est
des pièces longue portée mais là c'est
free pions il va forcément le voir et
c'est un gros pions parce que ça permet
de jouer des cinq et deux complètement
clôturer le centre et qu'elle prend 1,4
fois f6 du coup qui va arriver après
aussi voilà si fait cavaler prend 1,4
c'est un gros pion central de plus ça
fait très mal
et voilà le pion qui rentrent mais oui
monsieur mais oui monsieur grassi a
réussi à envoyer un fief si c'est des 5
et 17 kg est partout bon je sais pas
exactement comment faut continuer mais
tu gagnes ce pion tu gagnes des 5 tu tu
gagnes l'enfermement du fou et en plus
lui minutes 20 août ou une toux 5,40
après ya peut-être des trucs à base de
f3 cavaliers f6 qui les prend aussi si
on prend 1,6 dame prend aussi ses
chèques je vais quand même vous montrer
ça peut marcher des choses comme ça il
n'y a pas tous rêvent cette dame prend
ya le fou en machin et dame prend 1,7 à
du coup ça ça peut être une idée mais
c'est ok f3 ok si fait f3 en tout cas il
prend aussi ce juste il est trop fort il
méritait de gagner
ok si fait ça il mérite de gagner x q
c'est parce que ça c'est très dur à voir
et ça c'est juste du mérite de gagner en
fait que du coup c'est à dire qu'avec
les noirs il faut commencer par foued 6
après sarde pas les faux avis hacker
prend 2,6 quand même norme est ok si les
blancs on savait que ça marche c'est
bravo et qui a essayé 5 évitera ce qui
est cinq à 35 puis on prend ces cinq
épreuves 6 quand même ok non mais s'ils
voient ça c'est minimum niveau 2000 avec
le dam de b4 cavalli fin faire dame 2
pour b 4 cavaliers à quatre cavaliers à
4 e f 3 cavaliers f6 fou prend aussi si
on prend 1,6 dame 36 hockey il n'a pas
vu d'avancé c'est pure chance à près du
but the beat à 10 h où m6 qui prend
aussi si on prend aussi ce fou prend
aussi ses chèques crois je suis ok il
fait cavaler la haye mais merde il peut
le voir par pure chance [ __ ] il peut
voir du coup cavaliers prend kg on prend
le cavalier a attaqué voir cavaler prend
1,6 ok mais là c'est pure chance en fait
6 pour ça ok placé
pure chance en fait simple qui peut se
le prendre mais c'est malchance absolue
ça c'est
difficile à voir on va voir c'est un bo
dehors
on dit que ça aurait été bien le
problème de cavaliers g5 c'était une
autre tactique ch4 qui enferme le
cavalier plus de gaz
je pense j'ai pas je regarde pas leur
dis comme je vous dis il a fait cavalier
c'est 5 à 3 à 3 qui fait plaisir à 3 qui
est un coup complètement stupide c'est
cool ça c'est très cool ça c'est très
cool
donc là il
l'idée moi j'aime bien commencer par un
petit fou et si si si qui mange pas de
pain du coup il y aura plus de cavaliers
y aura pu les cahiers français 5
comprend ces cinq radars sur feux fiscal
français 5 sardes auraient le petit fou
prend des quatre échecs donc cavalier
prend b3
les pions
les trois
fofi 6 peut-être ok ça va
deux parties
bon maintenant il faut réussir à
remettre la marche avant avec les pions
avec avec du dessine cost income et
peut-être un fou des 5 peut être sympa
pour l'attaqué de pions b3 cavaliers
c'est si ceux ci un coup puis on prend à
trois peut-être pour pas donné de pions
après ses pions triplé 1
mais bon pourquoi le donner la parole
3 je pense qu'il est content de son
cavalier des cinq j'aime bien alors
après problème de des 500 fermes le flou
mais bon c'est pas grave
sur qui on prend il fera fou prend on
est là une belle position
maintenant il faut que ça se passe bien
fou prend b4 il va réattaquer la tour et
il faut transformer donc là il menace la
tour la tour 1 il va y avoir fou des
deux fous prend des deux prises des deux
qui sait si à va faire gaffe aux
cavaliers qui revient ces cinq ans
peut-être fou des deux il faut peut-être
joué food et six en fait il doit falloir
faire food et 6 pour menacer damas ch 4
étapes et partout food et si c'est dur
comme coup puisque c'est un coup vers
l'arrière mais l'idée c'est que ça
maintient le contrôle de la casse ces
cinq vous prendrez de dame prend des 2,6
cavalière avancé 5 le fou si le fou
bessette peut se retrouver un peu
faiblard avec food et si son contrôle
tellement de belles cases le fou est
tellement fort sur cette quasi contrôler
ses seins qui l'attaquent h2 et il
prépare damage 4 soudée
est trouvable mais difficile
un coup de marloux ça aurait pu être
dame h4 d'ailleurs pour laissez vous
prendre b4 dame prend des quatre échecs
et dame prend b4 très marleau il a fait
à 5 alors le problème c'est fou prend
pions prend cavaliers c5 qui peut être
chiant pour vous montrer ce fou peut se
retrouver un peu à court de cases ici et
les cavaliers domine un petit peu alors
après ça doit aller il ya quand même un
pion de plus mais il ya peut-être des
dames b6 il ya des choses mais faut
faire attention de pas se prendre ça en
tout cas là il a l'équivalent après fou
prend des camions granby cadre de deux
pions de plus quand même parce que ce
deux contre un il est bien bloquée donc
là s'il réussit à envoyer ses pions ça
va gagner bon c'est quand même un gros
avantage
non ça va quand même s'il réussit à
faire cavalier c6 qui va réussir à faire
échanger des cavaliers il va avancer les
pions et ça devrait gagner
tranquillement je suis assez confiant il
devrait filer en 2000 notre ami sarde
il devrait réussir à fil en demi finale
elles mêmes avantages qu'on imagine ans
il est un peu plus gros celui-là contre
benji l'avait un pion de plus mais il
avait pas davantage de la structure ici
il al'avantage la structure de pioncer
vraiment l'équivalent de deux pions
quasiment même s'ils perdent des quatre
ans fait ses deux pions que tu en es un
ou deux ça change pas grand chose
là il a quand même le centre qui avance
qui est mobile il a aussi un gros
avantage autant il peut l'amener au fond
il faut juste pas qu'ils jouent trop
vite mais surtout que
qui s'égrènent maintenant pour les
blancs c'est un problème parce qu'à ce
niveau là en dessous d'une minute malgré
leur âge ou de tancer beaucoup niveau
temps
vos positions il est bien faut juste
qu'ils jouent à sa main avec à et c5 et
la faux qui voilent dame b 6 en fait
faut qu'il fasse tout reprend tout
reprend et dames b6 hockey ou encore da
ration merde j'avais pas lu ok madame b
serait dommage j'aurais changé ce fou
que dit leur dit alors dit ouais mais
lord issa j'avais vu aussi mais ça y
trouvera jamais l'idée c'est sûr qu'il
prend bessette et adam b6 et le lin
cavaliers cloud et l'autre attaque et ça
il peut pas y penser
par contre ça ça ça qui est vraiment
dans ses cordes
il n'y a pas de bol parce que dame b5 et
mega fort d'un premier 5 et prend b5 et
là les cavaliers sont monstrueux ça
reste tendu 1
mais jean repoussé huit tours à huit on
sent que c'est chaud là ça fait un peu
peur il a fait tout reprendre un tour
prend 1 est la norme
d'un v6 et le coût qui est pas mauvais
qui doit être dans ses cordes vous ces
8es catastrophique fin catastrophique et
moche mais peut se jouer quand même et
d'un bep si c'est le coup logique car
elle est celle ci c'est vraiment le coup
fort il fait dame b6 ok il a trouvé on
va dire que dans le règne de ce qu'ils
pouvaient trouver il a trouvé le plus
fort bondam b5 et le quoi trouver ici
s'il ne trouve pas ça va très bien se
passer parce qu'il ya ce vis-à-vis ultra
désagréable pour les blancs et genre un
coup comme tour c'est un rêve a commencé
à voir des tours c8 et il va y avoir des
multiples clouage qu'ils vont gagner
pour sarde aller plus qu'une 50 mai
s'il fait tour c'est un tour c'est 8
c'est nickel trois minutes d'avancé tour
c'est un tour ces huit là ça cloud comme
ça ça cloud comme ça normalement ça va
se terminer assez rapidement la b5 ses
1600 1700 ouais ça doit être après 1600
1700 comme coût est trop dure à et la
tour c 8 et cavaliers à 6 ou cavaliers
ça doit gagner tout seul la tour c 8
c'est dead battu bastia en gros une
bande ça peut être pour ces huit dames
ces deux cavalières et 6 et c'est fini
en fait le cavalier tomber tout tombe il
ya trop de clouage d'ailleurs même
cavalier 17 cavaliers prend 17 on
pourrait se dire qu'il menace qu'elle
prend b6 et ça tient encore mais même là
il ya dame prend des quatre sur échec et
reprises ces deux et ça ça ferait un
math assez joli tour s'est vite jouée et
là c'est mon coeur qui priaient pour
dames b5
alors là il ya encore moyen de sauver
avec dame b 5 je pense moi il a fait
dame ces deux stations mais la dame b5
pouvait encore tenir prise b5 prise b5
et sur cavaliers à six cavaliers detroit
et ils étaient encore dans la game
mais il a fait dame c2 et cavaliers à 6
pour sarde comme prévu
et oui les amis ça fait le point et là
en plus ça va partir en tout reprend ses
cinq tours prend c1 dames prend des
quatre échecs
wen
la sapar cavaliers ainsi son plus ya
plus qu'une minute pour x cusset il n'a
pas déjoué boys et moins en moins
d'entraînements moins de stress moins de
pression ça marche toujours bien moins
d'échec-avant moins de pression plus de
repos et ça marche
caillé 17 et la dame prend des quatre
échecs et tout reprend ses deux il ya
tout reprend sa non non bon ça gagne
mais pourquoi
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
adam prend des quatre c'était fini bon
allez c'est fini quand même tomber un
tour b stourbe et ours tomber un tour b2
mais bon c'est des petites erreurs un
peu pénible mais manqué tour prend b2 et
cavaliers c5 et prend b3 il se passe pas
grand chose juste d'apprendre et 4
c'était instantanément dame s'était même
maths en fait c'est vraiment simple à
gagner ouais
un peu mais bon c'est encore fragile 1
m tour de pions de plus allez un petit
tour des deux parents chasse lecavalier
dans ça paraît logique
cavalli
5 pouces et 6 pas chercher des coûts
compliqué là il ya le cavalier qui
défend le pion tu chasses au pire tu
fais tour d2 qui avait les baies 5 pour
des trois tours prend b3 faut pas se
fatiguer là et j'ai 6 non c'est pas un
coût ultime geste ici mais ok voilà tout
reprend g2 faut ramasser les pions qu'on
nous donne un aux échecs
ça fait encore un pion de plus ok le
plus facile du tout reprend g de roissy
ce g5 matt si j'y arrive
mais bon 4 ça serait quand même bien de
faire tour des deux tours des trois
tombes et 3 c'est quand même le truc
scolaire bizarre ça que ce soit dur je
sais pas pourquoi c'est dur en fait on
et mettant des trois tours prend b3
voilà
il n'y a aucun
rien de cavaliers ça fait jamais rien en
b3 et
avec la tour et on pousse un c'est
bizarre de ne pas prendre ce pion quand
même tellement bizarre c'est quand même
le pion de thé envie de prendre pour
aller à dame
h 6 tours prend f4 mais ça sue pour
conclure
re 4
des cats
moi j'ai cinq ça va aussi de façon même
si lecavalier il regagner une qualité
même s'il a encaissé la qualité en fait
il a tellement de matériel en plus ok
voilà le roi prend 1,8 kg 6,3 g 7 il
prend un f4 était content je veux rester
avec les trois pions là faut vraiment
prendre et se laisser prendre la qualité
des échanges des changes
toutes ces pièces là tu restes avec avec
3,3 pur peinture est avec deux pièces et
trois pions de plus et voilà j'ai vu que
d'heureux bouger droit et de prendre un
f4 et là il ya plus qu'a pousser ça
gagne tout seul wei peur des fourchettes
mais ces coups-là y ait pas de
fourchette à avoir enfin c'est bien ils
pouvaient s'en prendre une de toutes
façons l'avantagé était trop conséquent
juste faire attention à pas prendre de
pâtes envoyé le pion à les faire une
dame là il peut pas y avoir deux pattes
maintenant la simplicité c'est bien beau
matin
trois dames contre roi dame g4 et le roi
qui monte
faut-il phase ça il peut faire damer g4
ok ça madame j'ai cinq dames g4 qui peut
faire des quatre est roi la rock'n roll
4 mais il y avait encore des
possibilités de pâtes avec le fou bref
trois est d'alger de maths
bon bah voilà 1-0 facile 1-0 très facile
les amis
je
je lui écrire
ça va ça va ça c'est bien
la première c'était exactement ce que je
pensais ça devait passer en tactique et
c'est passé excusez s'est préparé
ce thème de longues robes à très mauvais
conseils de fox greg qui veut nous faire
perdre avec des conseils pour y terrible
et s'est préparée contre les deux
allemands j'ai vu la prépa qu'il a fait
et donc normalement ça devrait bien se
passer
et oui les sillons canadien qui a essayé
de nous mettre qui essayent de nous
mettre dans le dur hikaru en sueur
non mais
c'était sûr y'a pas de ya pas de risque
que les gars je suis extrêmement
confiant on avis à paille a pas de
risque en fait le match up est parfait
voilà ça va
la prochaine et on doit doit doit être
très tranquille
ça
créée
à
oui car wash
faute de coacher juste avant la partie
des fois quand j'avais à peu près quand
j'étais en - dans moins de huit ans
petit poussin j'avais à peu près leur
niveau
c'est peut-être un peu mieux mais
j'avais à peu près leur niveau en gros
par une partie importante on avait fait
un coaching et ça a complètement fait
perdre la partie
je vais peut-être à 1500 1600 nan mais
je vois un peu mieux en vrai mais
à la flèche totale mais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai en fait j'y peux rien mais
mais en fait on m'avait coach juste
avant une partie comme ça pendant 20
minutes ça m'avait fait très mal joué
dans
mais ce n'est pas elle s'émeut l'on en
fait c'est juste une vraie anecdote
c'est pour comparer à ce niveau là quand
quand j'ai eu quelque chose de
comparable
le coaching de l'ast de lastminute m'a
complètement fait perdre mes moyens m'a
fait mal jouer en fait
non mais regardez c'est comme marquant
qu'on ait tout alors en interview il a
13 ans il est déjà plus fort que moi ce
n'est pas une question de flag c'est une
question que c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça il continue coach its cusset
et
on va voir
ok c'est parti on va voir s'il suit
sissach de suisse que je lui ai dit ok
si l'autre suisse après pas il va faire
cavalier ses 6 e 3 e 6 fou j'ai trois
fous des six f4
mais bon ok tu sors de chez eux trois
loties fait eu six fou j'ai trois fous
des six f4
compris l'a compris auquel
g3 et f4 pense qu'il peut le détruire
ouais et fous des 6 es fou des six f4
ça fait très mal
cross à lui fait tellement mal à ajka
roues
oui et oui ça ça fait très très mal je
suis fier bah ouais c'est une petite f4
r et voilà et voilà il ne tout près pas
pas de chance pour le joueur canadien à
ça ça fait très mal
la tête dit carrouché pro le chai voilà
faut qu'il fasse cavalier d2 machin qui
avaient des f3 food et trois qu'on
n'avait pas le temps de façon de faire
plus cher j'imagine hikaru en pls il car
audois grimacer de ouf
et oui les services de renseignement
pakistanais qui font très mal
alors là avec le fou s'est vite tu vas
des maires des vitrages m'ouvrit trash
mova lettrage trash mouche dans ton
chien c'est à dire terrible f4 edit ah
bah oui bah oui ça ça fait point hikaru
il faut apprendre à préparer car au kilo
a grimacé magnifique magnifique hikaru
qui doit suer à grosses gouttes
je suis mort de rire je suis mort de
rien ah oui on va là c'est là ces points
il tira au qui doit des dégoûtés
il doit être dégoûté et il sait que
c'est terrible ça c'est terrible a joué
sa tresse et arrive la joue et ça fait
impossible à jouer ok après il peut tout
se passer à ce niveau là mais en fait le
lit des c'est d'enfermer le fou c'est 8
ha oui rien me bats
thing about disent ah bah oui il fallait
pas préparé frères belges et un génie
bah oui mais là là je fais le point un
gros maintenant ça ça c'est as heard ça
sorte de finir le taf mais là là on l'a
mise dans le dans le driving sites comme
disent les américains
hikaru impossible que le coach français
préparer ça à pas de chance
abba et le coach français qui est un peu
plus malin que toi car on fait aller ce
total ah bah oui ah bah je peux
comprendre parce que ça ne serait pas
elle fait mal celle là elle fait très
mal
ces trois et puis va faire fou des trois
monts sarde
c'est pas gagné encore il ya encore du
f6 s'est pas fait encore si le trouver
si ça peut être relou paraît que ça
retrouve des dames h5 des trucs comme ça
mais bon on l'a bien sortie de
l'ouverture où des cavaliers f3 pour
maintenir le fou ces huit ans ferme et
ben salah
très très mal et maxime kinés des petits
vlad bah oui ça c'est ça les secrets de
lait des prés pakistanaise un maxime a
l'habitude a il a trouvé f6 ok c'est pas
gagné encore du coup ça m'a manqué un
peu de précision mais ok fouache 4 bien
jouer il peut y avoir du g6 mco mais bon
le roi va être faible c'est pas fini
ainsi peut nous voir un pion pour un fc
sion prend h qu'adam g cat est d'alger
sept matches si peut voir ça six voix
qui on prend un f6 comprend h4 d'alger
quatre dames g7 s'est terminée tu peux
le voir frérot il peut le voir aller on
n'en parle plus il peut le voir il ya
dame g46 qui peut être pas mal h5 dame
prend h 5 kg on prend et perpète kheddam
g4 jouer et sur h5 qui peut prendre ego
perpète et faire la petite nul
mais faut surtout pas qu'il le laisse se
libérer son fou
là il est bien quand même il a une telle
position sur pions prend 1,5 à foug
pranger cinq ayant une découverte qui
gagne l'adam telles à l'eau doit être
désespéré plus que 6 minutes qu'elle
prend 1,5 fort ouais ouais je sais max
mais bon est-ce a jamais joué 1 h 6
damage sinko tu laisses le fou et tu
fais perpète
ça pourrait pas fait fou détroit je
penche pour attirer pour fou des trois
personnes mais bon ça laisse les
cavaliers prend 1,5 à l'est pas si
simple qu'il ya plus on prend f6 aussi
qui peut être sympa dame prend et juste
fou j'ai trois pour h4 mais bon il peut
y avoir est non c'est dommage qu'il ait
il aurait vu le pion problème si c'était
fini et mesdames h5 dames cette dame g6
y a pas d'âme coup il ya dame prend 1,8
et damages 5 c'est vraiment fort mais il
va pas le voir je pense
damages 5 pour le père fait s'ils
écoutent les conseils qu'ils le voient
il peut encore la perdre au lac alors il
avait une tellement bonne position
le f 6 qui a fait mal
peut le voir il peut le voir 5
repousse que s'il fait nul en fait ça
gagne ce temps tu n'auras jamais père
pâtissiers ses coiffeurs
c'est nul pareil
coût damages 5 s'il le fait
c'est loin d'eux
la partie mais ça peut être cool hein
damages 5,3 g 7
non mais clairement c'est pas que ça
gagne mais bon tu vas faire fou détroit
après tu vas place était pièce mais
c'est juste que damages sein qui peut
faire plus on prend h4 et tu peux faire
annuler hince tentes et la fée foot est
roi
quand même puis on prend c'est plus
chaud que ça
l'être après ce point il peut laisser
peut faire fou g6 après tour f1 je sais
pas il ya plein il ya beaucoup d'options
à me suis pas bon dans ses protégés
j'espère roi
proposé par le chat est un match 5 mais
encore f5 les cinq minutes
f5 damage 5 ça c'est sûr qu'il l'a vu
est sûre pions prend h4 il aura la drôme
ok mais là ce qui est cool c'est qu'il
ya plus de pression sur le pion aux cinq
donc le fou c'est 8 va jamais sortir et
s'il fait damage 5 grand roque et g4
enfin si l'on voit ça ça va gagner tout
seul belge et trois serait dommage parce
que ça va aller
huit frappes vraiment voir d'un match 5
aura pourtant la presse
tellement bien marché quel dommage cette
prépare en or
mais dans 3
qui est prêt on s'inquiète un coup mais
ça va pas être vu
grosse récompense
ouais clairoix des messages mais non
mais j'en ai sage vous êtes complètement
taré les mecs sains c'est penser vu le
niveau de jeu des deux joueurs qu'il y
ait quelqu'un qui triche vous êtes quand
même complètement malade en fait c'est
enfin gers et c'est difficile de moins
bien jouer quoi en vrai il ya beaucoup
d'erreurs
alors là vraiment la position elle était
l'été cadeaux quoi t'en mets juste c'est
terrible en fait c'est presque
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs c'est
normal pour ce niveau là mais ya rien de
spécial ici
f3 pour revenir avec le cas mal ça va le
truc en fait c'est ce que j'explique
pourquoi il car ou dit que ça va être
dur ce qu'en fait il ya trop de pièces
d'excusés qui sont bloqués qu'elle a
excusé il faut des bons coups tu es là
ça m'inquiète
peu la rate et il a raté des super coups
sarde et là maintenant il est mal c'est
pas possible
prince était
cibl c'est choquant
excusez là il a joué quelques coups
excellent un ski c'est bien de jouer
quelques très bons coups mesdames g3
était vraiment faible
sûrement
f3 puis on prend un café prend hk très
bon après la position est très dur à
jouer pour les noirs l affaire qui avait
les prend
l excuse à a joué beaucoup de bons coups
d'affilée allez va peut-être craquer la
position reste hyper dur à jouer pour
les noirs honnêtement mais bon c'est
chaud
il reste plus de 3
un koh lanta excuces et il a toutes ces
pièces mal placé soit une bonne news qui
joue un coup de mer de ce côté là pour
qui est d'alger si ça peut pas rentrer
encore la même 80 est mûr adam g53 c'est
terrible il avait une tellement bonne
position par les forêts qui fasse grand
roque et qui ramène des pièces
bon coup à excuser qui a enchaîné
beaucoup de bons coups la sphère damage
3 se décaler
dans cas
c'est qu'il veut
coup j'ai six échecs qui sert à rien je
jouais damage trois droits des deux et
ramenée la tour mais bon c'est pas
facile à voir
et en gros ça ça peut être le plan ou
même d'un match 3 petit rock tour f 3
tours j'ai trois banques a career ferret
au nom il a s'échangent des dames non
pourquoi laisser les changes des dames
dans une telle position
donc c'est pas si simple a terminé pour
excuser quand même si ça rate ou bien
parce qu'il a des pièces qu'il a
beaucoup de mal à activer mais il faut
il faut il faut qu'ils commencent à va
jouer des bons coups la sarde aller
tourache trois tours h un cavalier f3 à
l'égard d'une position quand même avec
pas mal de vie pour lui aller
ça reste quand même plus que jouable
parce qu'il ya tour dh un cavalier f3 il
s'est ouvert la colonne h et une
nouvelle fois c'est il a encore le
bénéfice de la belle ouverture et la
ramène juste les pièces sur le roi est
finie le holà il a tellement du tour
alain cavalier froid surtout rejet et
s'ils seraient du g4 il pourrait pas
faire et francs il ya fou pranger 6e
peut pas faire tout reprendre bientôt
reprendre f6 t faut vraiment
juste les pièces est allé attaquer là il
a encore bien en vrai malgré la pièce
qu'il a perdu il est encore bien c'est
parce que donnent leur dis mais je suis
sûr que l'évaluation est pas est pas
terrible terrible oui c'est moins qu'un
70 mais c'est tellement plus simple à
jouer
2 c'est pas bien joué maxime suprême ces
réactions du sart qui a perdu la
confiance mais il peut se ramènent sur
ses pattes
ouais parce qu'en fait la position
depuis un moment elle est pas mal hein
au cas où mais c'est
à juste enchaîné attaqué le roi bêtement
là maintenant l'autre qui s'organise
excuses c'est ça joue bien aller tour
des achats faut quand même aller
attaquer un jour j'ai quatre maintenant
pour donner le pion non c'est
catastrophique
ok mais tu fais la même chose avec le
fou en d3 et c'est vraiment
catastrophique
allez tour
est ce ça s'est vraiment joué dans la
tête la prépa été parfaite tout était
parfait le fou qui revient en d3
maintenant voilà c'est un cauchemar à
l'écart il
six cavaliers fuite allez ça quand même
c'est cadeau et ça fait une calloc'h ça
fait pas gagner la game
mais ça fait revenir aller ça craque de
tous les côtés plus de deux minutes pour
x qc alessi peut faire cavalier prend la
fuite et tout rachat rapide ça peut être
cool
ok l'autre fait pour foot reprise j'ai
six c'est encore mieux parce que
maintenant il va perdre le pion h5 il va
perdre j'ai quatre fantastiques
quel est le seul truc s'il faut pas
qu'ils trouvent cavaliers cet ouvrage
cinq cavaliers f5 ton projet quatre
cavaliers prend 2,3 ok si tu trouves pas
ça se termine à dos on t'aime et s'il
trouve ça il mérite de gagner x q c'est
que ces variantes tactiques de trois
coups avec triple fourchette est sûre
fouet 8 je pense que juste faire fou
prend tout reprendre et tout rachat et
gagner les pions et les tours sont trop
fortes
allez fou prend h5 c'est cadeau il te le
donne prend le fpu pranger 4 après allez
ça ça fait
les ir du coup il fait là il vient de
récupérer qualité et deux pions alors là
il vient de faire très très mal et les
pièces noir réussissent toujours pas à
jouer à les fous pranger 4 et écoule
ward a les escaliers d'un peu la puce à
l'oreille mais c'est bien joué quand
même c'est même très bien joué en vraie
parce que si on reprend il ya tout
reprend g4 oulala ça va gagner
hikaru en pls ça c'est sûr hikaru w
allez tout reprend g4 est fou et fou
bouge c'est matt forcé tour penchée
quatre échecs 3,6 ou bouge mais oui les
amis 3,6 et fo bouge et sur walf 5 à
tour f1 math aller tour f1 c'est ma tu
en as tu peux le voir mais oui c'est
gagné et voilà terminé pour excuser à ce
terrible
la prépa d'hikaru en sueur bah oui mais
bon c'était sûr
et c'était sûr très bien joué ça fait
le taf hikaru en pls c'était sûr c'est
trop dur à jouer avec les noirs
stratégiquement il y avait un trop gros
une trop grosse avance parce qu'en fait
il est il est complètement bloquée avec
ses avec son fouet c'est juste trop dur
à jouer
c'est juste beau
coup trop dur à dre c'est juste
un avantage qui est énorme y donne quoi
leur dis comme avantage ici ok c'est
plus de à la sortie de l'ouverture c'est
l'équivalent de deux pions plus c'est
énorme en fait les attentes
ra peut-être le prendre en vocal bon je
vais laisser ce string j'ai retourné sur
ma chaîne du coup je vais peut-être
récupérer un petit ça redonne ambulants
vocale
en tout cas ça fait plaisir en herbe
le petit truc merci d'avoir suivi du
coup et je me rends voir je me rendrai
je me fais je me fais je me fais plaisir
et bravo à ça pour la victoire à tous